ich glaube jeder schon mal seinen
eigenen namen bei google gesucht und da
kommen wir dann sehr viele verschiedene
link und jeder hat doch irgendwie schon
mal seinen namen bei youtube eingegeben
und da kommen auch wäre sehr sehr viele
verschiedene video zum beispiel bei mir
wenn ich einfach mal ein bisschen
durchgegangen und habe dann irgendwann
dieses video hier entdeckt die wahrheit
über kongress da ich würde sie
angeschaut das wird mal zusammenhang
heute ist der tag x wieder gekommen an
dem die wahrheit über einen bestimmten
youtuber hätten anfangs einem youtuber
der auch video oder lieber heiß von
verschiedenen youtube hochlädt und heute
werde sein konnte
super da macht er mich dann mal als
beispiele nennt er das bild richtig gut
getroffen auf jeden fall ein wenn man
die namen spanischen halten mit mit
crafter mit wem er das letzte kraft
jetzt also auch noch ärger mit drin der
redaktion der bürger vom mittel dienten
videos wird ich würde sagen wir rufen
einfach mal direkt an und fragen was er
davon hält ein paar sekunden später
bleibt in dem hier von ihren zwar hat
man ein video hochgeladen die wahrheit
über kompakter und dort hat er
verschiedene theorien aufgestellt hat
auch wer wem was im statement dass du
einen burger namen gemacht hat
[Musik]
okay okay das wort essen geht hat er von
dem komiker die teckel brandung ist
angela davis hat ihn übertrieben ab mit
ebenfalls davor aber nicht für das
kinderprojekt alles klar
er kommt von meinem namen über mit kraft
über lte über anstellung mehr auf
project das ist dass das kann ich mir
tatsächlich dankt erklären da es auf der
trainer der eigentlich von vier
geschrieben wurde die sich aber eine
öffentlichkeit nicht zeigt wird zeigte
jedenfalls irgendwie kleines ensemble
dieses video bei youtube gesehen haben
kommen jetzt irgendwelche geheimnisse
formieren die öffentlichkeit er mich
total fertig und verdecken kommt dann
schwachen aber weiter mit dem video und
ich glaube wir waren weit vorne stehen
geblieben vom geläut von app greift sich
den sommer wieder genauer an wie bei
jeder weiß abdeckung den jeweiligen
anruf in diesem juni in dem neuen lied
von meinen namen drin sein konkreter und
luca aber das war nicht mein macbook
wort instagram account und jetzt werde
ich auch noch mit dem wort instagram
account verbunden
ich hoffe übrigens bei instagram folgen
hintereinander konnte lukas lukas
integra und wie man dieses spiel aber
wie man genau hinschaut und hineinruft
widmann dollar um von haring
bild mal genau an
[Musik]
flitterwochen familien dort nahmen
kommst du darauf keine sakramente mit
ihm geblieben und jetzt auf einmal kommt
er wird als werden durch du du bist der
tod
ich bin der tod also diese wahrheiten
offen
es geht noch weiter jeder buchstabe
steht dir wieder film bestimmten
buchstaben im alphabet immer die in eine
bestimmte reihenfolge ergibt das in 2004
und 2006 in der fichte 45 2016 um noch
mal kurz zusammenzufassen bin von meinem
namen über lte über ein solo märz über
ganz ganz viele stationen bis hin zu
meinem tod und jetzt noch einmal beim
zwanzigsten vierten angekommen haben was
an diesem datum gepostet genau an diesem
tag alter fenster kann hochgeladen
hiermit wird nicht legale 34 jahre was
auch intern hoch trotzdem können wir da
gerne folgen weil ich werde ab jetzt
täglich mit insgesamt vier machen
also wird ob jemals so voll wie bei
instagram dienstag
ja wir machen weiter mit dem instagram
welt deutsch wieder auf dem berühmten
rockefeller center dass ich in manhattan
new york befindet was es ebenfalls in
dieses werk gaggenau mediums radio marca
yamaha sowie das so bleibt wird wie ein
schwein 20
die hauptcharaktere lilly marge etwa nie
und robin wirken wie eine kleine
patchworkfamilie ungefähr genauso eine
patchwork-familie gab es schon macht bei
der serie poll hat bei der serie voll
wie lange geht das braucht die peak
route und beim poker dass die partie
wieder auf lukas attacken 50 diamanten
amphoren das 2005 haben leute wenn ich
zeigen weil die welt da draußen eine
starke community ich wünsche mir bei
ihrem video eur 555 1412 like leute
schaffen wir das also lasst mann leiter
und kräftig gerechtigkeit
ich habe gehört man ist als youtuber
dann besser wenn man erleichtert hatte
von italien die entsprechenden
buchstaben bekommen
wenn wir die entfernt dennoch eine
mathematik kann man sie ausgleichen
bekommen wir deb-auswahl heißt aber es
gibt diesen pulli hier im st
und er cool und es folglich auch
verkauft aber er ist cool also rechnet
man auch arbeiter mit dem werk führte
luca und viele male bei der firma beim
abtauen er war im internet internet
wurde von rabatten kann erfunden kann
oliver kahn der beste torhüter beim
fußball immer den ball haben beim deb
data dugard man-aktien super-talent
gemacht indem es nur von den kommentaren
h gefüllt bei der oberkörper frei das
video drehte operiert ob ein land kurz
an diesem tag wo ihre wunderschönen von
max ischia aufgenommen habe waren es in
frankfurt einfach witzig hat 44 grad
doch diese vorbei sagt also wenn ich das
wieder aufgenommen hätte dann wäre ich
jetzt glaube ich nicht mehr am leben
ja du bist der tod
wer würde sie gerne auch in youtube zu
zeigen aber dass lost in you tube
richtlinien doch nicht ganz genau kann
jack russell hat ja katja katja grafweg
caracas
[Musik]
okay das kann jetzt mit der wahrheit von
lukas müller ich jetzt wirklich drauf
klar meine wahrheit verknüpft sein kann
in einer wir sind wieder über elfer mehr
über oliver karneval über dem toten
vertrauen weiter kasse wird die größte
youtube wie die meisten tunnel der welt
in wicker das verkehrteste tunnel der
albula tunnel der in den alpen wird
findet bayerische alben feiern und
superflat daumenabdruck koma krankenhaus
schönbrunn mit lang nichts mehr ein was
ist dazu sagen soll 2012 in die welt
untergehen alles explodiert wie bei
einer bekam wie bei teenie der aktivste
vulkan afrikanische musik gelingt
wir haben die wahrheit herausgefunden
über computer alles hinter sein video
girl kollege vielleicht in meine
kollegen auch
er redet von breslau ich da an seinen
derzeitigen das ukulele für alle
verantwortlichen bei kanal geprüft also
wenn du das ihr wie ich weiß wird gerade
im urlaub
du hast gerade im block während glock
gedrehten alle meine kollegen und ich
würde mich aber sehr freuen wenn du bald
zurückkommen damit wir dann videos
aufnehmen können
ja roccoli bitte komm zurück ich weiß
mich auch kollege dieses video hier
sehen wir aber wie begrüßt die aufgabe
den hashtags überbreiten hashtag
comeback kolonie und ich hoffe irgendwie
erreichen wir dann ukulele ich auch
nicht fehlen und ich hoffe dass kollege
dann bei dir hier wird mir videos
prämiert
und das war auch schon von deiner
wahrheit über mich wo wir festhalten
können das ukulele an allem schuld
das war die familie meine damen und
herren wenn euch das ganze projekt mäßig
dabei halten und auch vom team dann
würde ich mich mal live freundschaften
nicht aus um ein viertes angesehenen
videos zu überbieten
ihr findet jetzt weil die eigene braucht
ihr könnt ihm einen kanal abonnieren
freecom onlineshop verlinkt und ihr team
kann das video eingeblendet was bestimmt
auch
ich hatte eigentlich noch